herrlich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zum zu einer weiteren folge
games zusammen mit komme ich war beim
friseur sieht kacke aus ich weiß wollte
ich eigentlich organ das war echt doof
entscheidungen soll wir sind in der
pokémon napier man direkt noch drehen
sollen für euch auch das dings man
stirbt dann ja nicht überlebt das immer
ja ich habe mich in game mode gesetz
einfach so ist es natürlich das
schlauste machen kann
ok mach ich doch auch direkt die machen
jetzt nämlich sehr gerne uns waren wir
da schon ein dickes und nicht achtet
neben nicht onyx kleinstein und die
weinstein kämpft gegen das kaputt oder
hinten und ich kämpfe gegen kummer weil
ihm ein bisschen lauter damit ihr wisst
was hört so hörte jetzt was man isst und
wir haben schaffe ich diese sprung nicht
wie schlecht bin ich will ich bin sauer
ich bin schon voll weit ja ja ja ich
glaube das genau meine karte sind mittel
marketplace kreditkarte hallo
nein du bist richtig da komme wir haben
jetzt übrigens gesagt dass wir so haben
wir nicht gesagt aber wir beschließen
das grab formal geht immer wieder zurück
auf den block wohl einfach immer wahre
herausforderung
wir haben das einfach so ist die
selbstverständlichkeit der guckt sich so
unsere videos steht kein wort bei und
fest fast sich nur eine kopflose ist
also wir sind eigentlich zwei wir sind
uns hier darauf lagen wirtschaft wer
trotzdem nicht mehr
das geht doch gar nicht schlecht wäre
weil gott wie soll das funktionieren
die ganzen zeitspringen welche aber ist
echt cool macht somit diesem pixel
ja das ist die idee komme
ich glaub ich ein falsch gesprengt habe
ok oh nein alter unglaublich einfach so
scheiße war dann eigentlich zwei w
ja ich bin drin diese waren eigentlich
zwei wege gefragt dass ich mich dort die
teens mails verschickt wurden lassen als
ob das ist eigentlich voll krass alle
fische sind so kannibalen
die snb ist also fische voll krass wird
menschen essen so ist das wäre nichts
für mich war er mich an und warte auf
nicht da bin ich wurde die idee zwischen
bettchen
wir haben uns halo ist dass ich packe
med
wie kommen wir denn hier hoch und müssen
wir drüber springen eines traders an ich
geschlafen
die crazy bob sind immer schön endlich
wieder ohne frage ich mich das wurde mir
nie weggenommen
voll krass ich habe aber die opel
gemacht hätte die den sprung da geht
doch gar nicht oder ich hab dich du bei
mir steht natürlich froh hier kein
problem ich hab's auch gerade geschafft
ist das wirklich schwierig aber ich hab
ihn geschafft in den auswahlmannschaften
von dem game mode bin einfach mal warnt
jedoch klar welchen schaffen kommen
innerhalb von st
wenn du da weg gehst auch manja kuhl wie
man das machen müsste da müsste man ja
mal vor du fällst sie ins wasser wenn
wir nicht im gamer werden um ist alles
noch mal von vorne springen und ich hab
gerade eine kiste gefunden dass eine
holzkohle drin wie der woche fliegt aber
wir sind ja falsch kann hier ich stelle
hier solchen dann hin
hier kannst du nicht auf die leiter so
ein bisschen drauf
doch um dann hier und dann hier drauf
ich mache alles was du mir sagst es
mache ich da hinten lang janina vollert
ricky hatton euro ohne springen kommen
können nein
doch das ist so blockiert da kann man
nicht anspringen
das alles zwei hoch crazy besteht dass
wahlleiter was wäre ein schild gewesen
die schon blinken aber wir kommen aber
auch heute wieder voran nennt das auch
sein kann wo wie wie krass wie einfach
sind woran liegt das nur an einen
wirklichkeit haben wir zielwasser
getrunken
komme ich meinem tollen bild von krebs
gibt eigentlich 179 shader
noch nicht dass man hier entlang
verdrecken michalskis welche wege die
profis wir können uns gar nicht rollen
so richtig weil wir bei dem game mode
sind leider ist immer wieder raus du
brauchst du doch gar nicht nein da fehlt
mir etwas runter ging welche bio-gate
0,3 watt ich habe keine berechtigung in
den befehl auszuführen
ich hab dir ihm klar wird dann kann ich
mich ja selbst auch nicht im game 1 0
machen
nein lass es nahe kommen ja okay ist
schön
dennoch man komme ich brauche gegen
heute nicht hoffe dass nicht wieder da
hoch bekomme ich komme jetzt nicht hier
darauf komme ich mal nur an dich krank
hat nicht hallo ich komme leider sonst
nie wieder hochgekocht
ich muss man sich alles von vorne von
onyx anspringen ja danke ich sehr
komisch
nein der letzte sprung verdammt so wo
bin ich denn hier gerade aha natur eine
holzkohle gefundenen top ich hab auch
schon mal wie viel holz cola ist
eigentlich commander letzten folgen also
ein bisschen geträumt müsst ihr wissen
immer was du gemacht hast letzte
empfiehlt den meisten wahrscheinlich gar
nicht auf als der kernkraft habe ich
sagen geschrieben ja ich bin ich brauch
noch mal im moment denken wie ich bin
noch duschen oder sonstwas mehr
geschrieben und auf jeden fall habe ich
mir gesagt in der zeit da kann ich ja
mal eben hier etwas auf der karte vor
präparieren da habe ich einfach mal
angedacht aber auch mit aufgenommen in
die folgende drei englischen immer
anfangen dass ich mal einmal die betten
abbauen damit du einfach keinen punkt
mehr hast und ich das auch immer wieder
mache ich eigentlich witzig wenn und den
grünen block einfach ein höher setzt
habe ich nicht einfach gemacht wie soll
ich denn sonst da hinkommt du gehört die
leichte anderer seite
ja ja und was auch dann habe ich es
nicht denn darunter keinen sinn ich war
doch schon drauf doch da in einen zaun
sprung präparierten mal einmal höher
gemacht haben wir runter gemacht ich
verstehe die reaktion bekommen kräftig
wie ich bin nicht dumm oder was da waren
noch nicht so hoch und ich mal so jack
äckern komme dass ich verstehe das nicht
immer ich springe an dieser leiter rande
nicht ich leider immer weg wie sie jetzt
ging es auch aber ich bin sonst mal weg
geschleudert
auch jetzt hat den nächsten sprung ist
hole dann hätte er das verdammt gut da
so etwas verstellt
ich hab gleich ziel verstellt es geht
auf jeden fall noch verdammt jetzt auf
dem hof zu sprinten einfach verdammt
verdammt verdammt
nein nein da und hab und ja jetzt
geschafft wo bist du du hast hier schon
die holzkohle ausgenommen natürlich bist
wahrscheinlich diesen cup braun gang
durch gelaufen wenn ihr über dir hallo
herr ohne sprinten einfach auf so und
jetzt ohne sprinten dann musst du den
nächsten sprung mitsprinten
okay so also er ja aber ich war darauf
hab ich bin ich laufe da immer wieder
zurück weiß vielleicht so in der
intention wenn das intuition intuit dass
ich jetzt nicht schaffen samstag viel
witziger wenn wir jetzt eben links wären
er wäre total witzig hier muss man das
über ich hab's geschafft
muss jetzt das kann das kann auch nicht
machen
jetzt kann man nicht man das jetzt geht
nicht das geht alter warum schaffe ich
das nicht mehr
ich kannte diese gleiche geheime
wegnehmen weil ich die op weggenommen
habe hält es geschafft auf diesen
komischen holzblock betreuer versprechen
schafft wie crazy bekomme
das ist total irre ein profi wie gegen
das jetzt ich kann da nicht mehr
springen wenn ich da draußen einfach nur
schiff drückt man einfach übertreibt mit
nicken ja ach so ja dann noch mal vor um
die ecke gucken und dann ganz vorsichtig
rüber ok go schalter wir sind weiter und
erschafft für hühnchen ich habe hier
ganz viel nahrung noch gefunden nein
nein
du wartest aber erst noch nie bist du
fertig bist du und das tier musste ich
mir jetzt mal hier so ein bisschen so
ich habe es nie geguckt die diese ecke
nein
hongkong crafter älter was ist los mit
dir ich sie hasse solche ich hasse
leiter sprünge über alles shift drücken
shift rückkehr ist soll jetzt bewegt
sich ja nicht in hitchcocks gehst du
ganz nach oben bei deiner leiter ist
wären naja wenn ich und jetzt guckst du
diese ecke die genau hinguckt an die
obere ecke hier ja und da geht es
einfach über mit schiff druck und weht
rücken wenn ich ganz langsam rüber sein
und ist ganz klar oft wie uns genau
stark läuft
congratulations chef komplette pokémon
challenge presley button to come back
na
ld hat ja leute stellt euch auch auf die
nächsten acht folgen mit einer membran
und alles so schön dunkel hier ja sogar
irgendwie youtube ich hab eine fackel
war gesetzt ich mache ich warte mal ich
will erst mal rum und das jetzt was ist
das saints row the saints row abstimmung
dieses ganze nie lange über die sprünge
gehen eigentlich wäre jetzt nicht so
scheiße ich mach jetzt erstmal ihr licht
und natürlich ganz gut wieder ein game
und machen dass wir immer wieder hoch
fliegen kann sonst hat das recht zu
lange als news und wenn der einband
sprung geschafft haben wir ihnen dann
noch mal machen
bisher ist so ein bisschen dran ist dass
die sache angehen
es ist aber relativ easy alter
eigentlich
ich finde unsere taktik da mit dem mit
dem game mode und dann springe ich die
beste aber eigentlich bei solchen karten
hier wurst unendlich weit hoch gedicht
ich gucke ja ich bin ja immer noch nicht
ganz oben angekommen obwohl ich fliege
und wir müssen ja nachher hochspringen
es dauert ewig keine holzkohle guck mal
nach oben
guck dir meine tormann wie hoch der ist
glaube ich die die sichtweite war noch
nicht mal aus
ein schalter gedrückt den ich gefunden
habe analysten gerade ich bin ja schon
dran macht überall fackeln kann
ach so du setzt gerade setzen hier cool
man kann sein spawn hier setzen das ist
stark macht
online leiter springe ich erleuchte hier
erst mal den kompletten raum kann man
eventuell da ein wo man noch an die wand
schlagen wir möchten wenig licht ja horn
leiter springmann ich war schon so weit
oben was bald also auf jeden fall war
ich oben angekommen unterschied ist
wirklich schlecht so wenig nicht machen
was sagst du ist doch super komme ich
gut dass du dir nicht machst aber
trotzdem hätte ich lieber gerne dass du
mich hier unterstützt ok dann komme ich
direkt
tp crafter soll dieser sprung so ich bin
bei dir
dieser sprung darauf die leiter pass auf
du musst dich hier in die ecke stellen
ganz mit mit shift bei mir wo ich kann
es stehen der ecke ok dann ganz am rand
stellen aber mit dem ganzen die ecke
drücken
ja du jetzt loslassen würdest du würdest
die leiter wieder runter rutschen
deswegen einmal ganz kurz auf krücken
ein bisschen stück drüben und jetzt
doppelt wir und dann ganz schnell rechts
dann darüber springen halt noch mal und
dann natürlich shift wird rücken und
hier hoch danke so stark wie schafft er
das ist genau meine möbel diese ja ich
habe und jetzt fliegt mal nach oben
wenn du jetzt schon sagst daß ich sehe
ja nicht das ende
ja ich war kommt immer mehr aus dem
nebel raus wir sind hier ja deswegen
dann müssen wir halt alles immer wieder
so hier um hier um autogramme nein wo
willst du denn hin und nicht einfach das
einliter muss mal schauen wir ob du in
den blöcken leitern hast meistens haben
sechs sprüngen leitung selbst geschafft
westermann oder aber es sah man da
warten sehr schön aber das ist stark
ging ich finde ich mag dass es ist nicht
so hart weil kommt noch ich sagte es war
überall bei jeder karte bei jedem karten
abteil hier so dass erst die harten
level weiter oben kam der kuckuck merken
wir schon sagen du hast den richtigen
profi nehmen die sitzen auf jeden fall
wir wollen grill
die folge ist auch schon wieder vorbei
wir sind 18 eine kürzere folge machen
leute heute aber leute heute aber wir
wollten grillen und da bin ich jetzt
auch schon viel zu spät und haben daraus
auch schon angefangen das ja wenn ich
weil ich ja im erdgeschoss wurde und
denkt wie ich verliebe freuen wenn es
euch gefallen hat wir probieren es
wiederum gerade wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann lasst doch bitte ich schaffe
einen längeren sprung nicht ich auch
nicht persönlich für ihn nicht gehen ja
den den meinte ich jede nacht kommt noch
eine viel schlimmere naja gut leute die
nächste folge ist morgen bekomme da
schaffen weil die map dadurch wir sind
schon bei der vierten recht für doch
stimmt ja das ist schon das vierte leute
so stark wie web.de so lange wollten
dass ihr der difficult die sun schreibt
so hart hart hart hart mittel
egal ob wir es euch gefallen hat noch
zeit mit einer bewertung und sonst wie
ich sagen sie ist nicht mal wieder oder
als kommentar